what's up everyone it's Warren and we
have some big news today in regards to
Avengers in game and Captain Marvel so a
few months ago samuel l.jackson came out
in an interview and said that Captain
Marvel can time-travel this was
obviously huge news not just for the
Captain Marvel movie but for Avengers
endgame
we know that the Avengers are going to
try and undo the snap somehow and we
know time travel will most likely be
involved somehow
so with Sam Jackson dropping that bomb
it appeared like we found the way The
Avengers were going to go back in time
this was obviously a huge reveal and it
did leave a lot of people wondering how
ant-man a time vortex and the quantum
realm were going to play a part in
Avengers in game if Captain Marvel can
travel through time after all we do have
a ton of leaks with the Avengers wearing
these white suits believed to be for
traveling inside of the quantum realm so
this was pretty confusing but as it
turns out samuel l.jackson was trolling
us in a recent interview with KROQ
samuel l.jackson admits that he made
that up and he was just blowing smoke
when he said that no you just made stuff
up that made stuff up I say she could
time-travel one time which was
completely from yeah just jacked
everybody and we didn't have to kind of
backtrack from that a couple of times he
like I was just blowing smoke yeah we
just been mistake we were tired end of
the day I had a bunch of people bring
reporters to sit and you're working all
day and they go they want you to stop in
the middle of the day and go talk to a
table full of people for no reason you
know it's like clearly Sam Jackson meant
no harm when he said that he was just
trying to keep everybody in the dark and
he even says that he said it by mistake
but this certainly does clear up some
things as I said before it was pretty
confusing when we found out that Captain
Marvel could in fact time-travel and now
that we know she can't time travel it
actually makes avengers endgame a little
bit less diluted so this is great news
for Avengers in game because there's
already going to be so much going on and
definitely puts the main focus of
time-travel back on the quantum realm
and the time vortex that was mentioned
in ant-man and the wasp so let me know
what you think about this brand new info
that we received in the comments down
below and reminder I started a new iMacs
giveaway if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win five imax tickets so you
and some friends can go see Avengers
in-game in theaters all you have to do
is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]